it's been a long time Kyle for his team
for his girlfriend Kerry Simmons and for
the man himself Boris Johnson's dream
fulfilled
he's our new prime minister good
afternoon I have just been to see her
majesty the cream who has invited me to
form a government and I have accepted
and with one mission to finish what he
started
reflects it the people who bet against
Britain are going to lose their shirts
but there's working to restore trust in
our democracy and we're going to fulfill
the repeated promises of Parliament to
the people and come out of the EU on
October 31st no ifs or buts and we will
do a new deal a better deal he won the
referendum but he broke the country and
his party now his chance to fix it I had
every confidence that in 99 days time we
will have cracked it but you know what
we aren't gonna wait 99 days because the
British people have had enough of
waiting the time has come to act to take
decisions to give strong leadership and
to change this country for the better he
wants a deal but is willing to leave
without one it is of course vital at the
same time that we prepare for the remote
possibility that Brussels refuses any
further to negotiate and we are forced
to come out with no deal not because we
want that outcome of course not but
because it is only common sense to
prepare a preemptive strike on Europe
but he knows it's his job on the line -
I will take personal responsibility for
the change I want to see never mind the
backstop the buck stops here a domestic
agenda sketched my job is to make your
streets safer
and Willingham in with another 20,000
police on the streets my job is to make
sure you don't have to wait three weeks
to see your GP I am announcing now on
the steps of Downing Street that we will
fix the crisis in social care once and
for all
a scattergun speech mr. Johnson promised
in the world
let's change the tax rules bits promote
the welfare of animals cut co2 and
tackle climate change and produce green
jobs for the next generation peddling
optimism to the very end no one in the
last few centuries has succeeded in
betting against the pluck and nerve and
ambition of this country they will not
succeed today we in this government will
work flat out to give this country the
leadership it deserves and that work
begins now thank you very much
only one thing in the entry in truth his
Premiership hinges and wrecks it a
lesson he's learnt from his predecessor
earlier today she faced the Commons for
the final time mr. Johnson conspicuous
by his absence Theresa May has felt the
weight of responsibility a public
servant to the end that duty to serve my
constituents will remain my greatest
motivation
but her premiership ending in failure
and in tears
[Applause]
she lost the support of her party but
one man has never left her side finally
and most of all I want to thank my
husband Phillip who's been my greatest
supporter and my closest companion that
wasn't me
I think the answer to that is I think
not I'm about to leave Downing Street
but I'm proud to continue as the Member
of Parliament for Maidenhead I will
continue to do all I can to serve the
national interest and play my part in
making our United Kingdom a great
country with a great future a country
that truly works for everyone as she
leaves office most of her cabinet go in
with her some of them are willing to
serve in a Johnson government but most
simply not in banking in recent weeks
it's felt like nothing could stop mr.
Johnson's ascent though these protesters
briefly did to the Queen this the moment
it became official friendly cheers is
our new prime minister departed for
Downing Street in to number 10 and
straight to business assembling his
brexit delivery team total overhaul of
the top team Sajid Javid his Chancellor
Priti Patel Home Secretary Dominic Rob
to the Foreign Office
nearly everyone from the may era has
gone team Johnson bringing in those who
fought with him in the vote leave
campaign into frontline posts and behind
the scenes - because this is not about
unity this is about brexit delivery and
he is a p.m. already at war his
opponents in the party and in Parliament
already preparing for the conflict mr.
Johnson knows his success or failure in
office depends on getting brexit done in
the next hundred days his could be a
very short reign
and into number 10 and to battery better
atleast I news watch mister
[Applause]